so when you go back into let's say if
you want to call the mainstream
population I don't know what the for
lack of a better word and you see people
that come to classes or whatever and
they and they challenge different
beliefs about story structure or writing
or the need to take classes or whatever
do you see that they are justified in
being angry about certain things because
sometimes you look at how angry people
get over something is innocent a
screenwriting and you say what's the
justification for that you can take it
or leave it like if you you know take
what you like leave the rest kind of
thing yeah and and some people seem very
dogmatic about certain things and it
becomes it's almost like a fight about
religion when it's just screenwriting
right well I don't you know I those kind
of those people don't stay very long in
a class and I also I have no desire to
argue with people or write and that's
not true my interest as a writing
teacher is to get to the truth so if
somebody's arguing with me about
something or or or or astonished Lee's
holding a position my question is is
that true is what you're saying true
let's explore that let's examine it
because I have no dog in this race I
don't I'm not dogmatic at all I have
yeah I've been teaching a long time and
writing a long time and I've got a you
know III I've I've got a method that I'm
that I'm teaching people but I don't
even know if I would actually call it a
method process that I'm teaching and but
yeah I don't really I don't get into
fights with people about writing it's
like you really believe that and you
you're so you're so staunchly holding
that that point of view well then then
good how's it working for you
you know is it is it is it helping you
with your writing if it is then great
and if not then you know I I see it a
lot with writing teacher
I think there are a lot of writing
teachers who are it's almost like
they've got to secure their their sort
of place in the world by issuing
everything that isn't what they teach
and that can be I've seen it a lot where
the latest thing is that that some
writing teachers say the three-act
structure is dead it's it's it's
remedial its it it's it's not going to
it's it's going to kill any creativity
and the problem with that is that they
don't understand what the three-act
structure is because the three-act
structure is has nothing to do with
plotting in my opinion and unfortunately
the a lot of story structure is taught
by story analysts who are sort of
brilliant left brain left brain errs and
are really adept at deconstructing a
masterpiece and and sort of the
implication is that now that we've
deconstructed this you should go off and
write your masterpiece and while there's
tremendous amount of value in in in
studying film theory or you know film
theory because it's that that's that's
you know deconstructing Casablanca or
Citizen Kane is is going to help you
understand how a story was built some
degree but it's not going to teach you
process it's not going to teach you how
to organize your ideas when you look at
a movie like Casablanca and you think
about the Epstein brothers writing you
know we're structuring this this movie
they I'm interested in in the process
I'm interested in how did somebody come
to write this in other words you can you
can sort of like just because you
deconstruct something so it's like
you can't you can't take something dead
and look at all of its existing parts
and then and then reanimate it it's not
going to come back to life and so just
because you can break down this thing
into its it's sort of separate parts
doesn't mean you're going to uncover the
mystery of what the thing actually is in
other words story structure is really
the DNA of your protagonists
transformation that makes sense the
story centers the DNA of a protagonist
transformation it's not you know in the
midpoint there should be a reversal like
I don't even know what that means you
hear it all the time with with these
story analysts that should be reversible
what the hell does you know does does
it's a wonderful life have a reversal
that's where mr. Potter offers Jimmy
Stewart a job and Jimmy Stewart says no
I don't know I I don't I think of I
think of story structure as not a
conceptual model something we can figure
out but it's it's more of a experiential
model in other words your protagonist
goes through a series of experiences
that lead to a transformation and I
think if story structure as an immutable
paradigm for a spiritual transformation
it's immutable it never changes but that
doesn't make it that doesn't that
doesn't limit your creativity that
actually paradoxically opens your
creativity in other words when when you
really understand what story structure
is it moves you beyond your limited
imagination of what your story is I
always tell my writers your idea of your
story is not the whole story it's not
that it's incorrect it's that it's
incomplete and so if you were to distill
story structure to three words it would
be desire surrender transformation so
show me any story there's you're gonna
have a character that wants something
desire you're gonna have a character
that lets go of the meaning
made out of their goal surrender you're
gonna have a character that experiences
transformation in other words a shift in
perception a reframing of their
relationship to their goal show me a
story that doesn't have that and I'll
show you a story that doesn't work you
know or is really experimental okay but
that's where that's where when people
you know I I have I it happens not when
I teach so much as as if I do a lecture
it to a bunch of people there's always
the the the sort of the contrary and the
person who's like you know I don't agree
with that and I'm like that's great
let's let's talk about that but it's it
it's it's it's usually about something
that they're trying to work out with
themselves and it's not really it's it's
it's it's usually that they I don't know
it's usually like they want they're
looking for some kind of fight rather
than they're actually sincerely
interested in in deepening their process
you